هناك سر في هذه الحفرة ،
يفضّل المسؤولون منك عدم معرفة
أننا أسقطنا كاميرا على بعد عشرات
الأمتار من الحجر الجيري الصلب
للكشف عن نفق متطور
مكتمل
بأضواء تهوية ، وهو كبير بما يكفي
ليقف لاعب في الدوري الاميركي للمحترفين في إسرائيل.
حزب الله ،
الجماعة اللبنانية المسلحة التي لها صلات
بإيران
، كان من المهم
للجيش الإسرائيلي الحفر
بالقرب من هذا الجدار قدر الإمكان ،
وذلك لأنه
على الجانب الآخر من هذا الجدار يوجد
لبنان وما أرادوا إظهاره هو
كيف
بدأ نفق حزب الله في لبنان.
ودخلوا إسرائيل ليجدوا هذا النفق على
الرغم من أنه لم يكن كثيرًا على
ما رأوه ولكن بالأحرى على ما سمعوه
اهتزازات [موسيقى] من الحفر تكشف عن عمليات الحفر التي
يظهرها هذا الفيديو عندما
اكتشف المسلحون اللبنانيون لأول مرة
أن أنفاقهم لم تعد سرًا في
هذا الفيديو  نرى
انفجارا ما الذي يمكن أن تخبرني به
أن الانفجار
قررنا عدم قتل أولئك الذين
يسيرون
في الأنفاق كان تحذيرًا  أو
الجانب الآخر للبقاء خارج
الأنفاق ولدينا أنفاق أه
خيانة تم
الكشف عن أربعة أنفاق حتى
الآن يتوقع الجيش العثور على المزيد وتقول إسرائيل
إنها تنتهك وقف إطلاق النار الذي دام اثني عشر عامًا
وتحقق قوات حفظ السلام التي تراقب الحدود
بشكل سري.
توفر التكنولوجيا المتطورة موقعًا ، ثم يبدأون في
الحفر ،
فهناك هامش ضئيل للخطأ إذا كانت
التدريبات على بعد
نصف متر إلى اليمين أو نصف
متر إلى اليسار ، فهذا يعني
أنك لست في
النفق وأنت '  إذا لم تحقق
هدفك مثل العثور على إبرة في
كومة قش ،
فالأمر أكثر تعقيدًا ، حيث يقول الجيش إن
الكشف عن الأنفاق مبكرًا
قد حد من التهديد ولكن كان لديهم
القدرة على
إلحاق ضرر كبير بإسرائيل بآلاف المدنيين
الذين يعيشون بالقرب من الحدود في  خطر
الاختطاف أو ما هو أسوأ من ذلك ، قال مسؤول كبير في حزب الله
لشبكة CNN إن المجموعة
فوجئت بعملية إسرائيل ،
لكن لم يتم تأكيدها أو نفيها أنها
كانت تحفر أنفاقًا في
غضون ذلك.  يواصل "إل"
حفره لتعزيز الأمن
على الحدود الشمالية لإسرائيل مع
لبنان